let's go next to the caller calling in
from the four seven eight area code
who's calling in today from four seven
eight hi yes my name is Tammy
hey Tammy what I'm calling from Georgia
Rita sure well I had a well thank you so
much i watch your show all the time
my question is at this point you know we
have elected officials going on TV
saying they absolutely will not uphold
their oath of office because they're
going to cover up for trump at what
point do we as citizens have enough
legal basis to file a civil suit against
these people that are basically causing
all of us harm you know with their
behaviors I mean listen we probably
already have a basis to do it in the
sense that the interest of the American
people have not really been represented
by our elected officials for a very long
time the thing is though as soon as you
do it what what Court is going to allow
that to move forward right and even if
you get some lower court to allow it to
move forward where it's just
unfortunately because what you are what
you're trying to fight Tammy is the
system that has put in place those who
control every aspect of the judiciary
the executive branch the legislative so
we probably already have a basis to sue
on that on those grounds but it's just
not going to go anywhere unfortunately I
see you know it it's just so still like
you know at this point yeah we can
impeach and we can do all the subsets or
we can try yes we are now but it does
start to at what point does it get too
much in our favor you know and that a
suit might at least bring some attention
to the fact that there are other
ramifications for their age I wish you
were right I think I think it would go
nowhere but while I have you on the
phone since you're coming from Georgia
what's going on with the voter
suppression there we've reported you
know that hundreds of thousands of
people are attempted to be purged from
the voter rolls and that it's getting
continuing to be really ugly is is there
anything
new going on you can tell me about well
I can definitely say you know during the
last election I live in a predominantly
Republican County and we had you know
like six voting places in our town it
was very good for you in a Republican
part of the state to get to get to vote
and to not have a long line it sounds
like Oh awfully so I'm just in the place
where I both there were six functioning
machines you know and we we didn't you
know we're a small County you know we we
only have I would say less than 15,000
in our County total and you know but I
do know a few people that have been
bumped off yeah I personally haven't
because I'm an avid boater right you
know so I think they can't me but you
know I'm sure they would love to well
part of Georgia you are going to have no
problem voting in November that's the
good news I guess
yes you know I guess that's about the
best what you get from it yes all right
Tammy yeah yeah it sounds like it we're
going to keep covering right thank you
all right thank you so much all right
Tammy from Georgia great to hear from
her